So to wrap up, we went over how the IK2Bone function works and
how you would set that up in your control rig.
We made a custom function and then learned how to set up a function library
with the ability to share our custom functions across the entire project.
We learned a couple of different ways to set up our finger controls,
depending on what possibly works best for your rig.
We also did some work with nulls to help add an extra layer of control within your control rig.
And lastly, we explored a new control type, the float control,
and learned how to convert the values from that control into rotation
and drive another set of controls with its movement.
So hopefully now you have a better understanding of some more of the functions and features found within control rig
that you can take away with you to develop and improve your own rigs.
Thank you very much for taking part and following along if you did.
Feedback is always welcome for the course,
so if you have anything to share, please do get in touch.
But otherwise, best of luck with your control rigs.